oh I got
a okay
oh so oh
okay okay hello everyone I'm Terrence
from continuity um so while sui is
putting on the slides I would like to do
a quick survey so how many of you have
have heard of yan had
Yan okay how many of you have used
it one okay uh it's good so had Yan is a
pretty new thing uh sometimes you call
it haduk 2 if some of you might notice
um okay so I got the slides um so today
is mainly talking about had Yan and also
a library called weave that we build to
ease the use of yarn uh for everyone
developers like like
us so okay um before I go into go deep
into the the Yan and WEA um so where am
I and what the continuity company doing
so continuity is actually a startup
company that focus on trying to um
making like turning every Java
developers or every developers into B
data developers okay uh in order to do
that we build a platform called Rea
platform that allows like uh any
programmers can write Big Data program
applications very very easily uh so one
of the things that we allows developer
to do is uh what we call realtime stream
uh event processing like storm or S4 or
the latest Samson
um so they're kind of a similar category
real time uh stream event
processing uh and in continuity we have
something called back throw and uh it's
it's a real time streaming event
processing and it's tightly integrated
with the Hado uh stack with Edge Bas as
a storage with had Yar as the runtime
system uh and it has a lots of nice
property around it uh I'm not going
going through the details but there like
transactions uh on top of xrays that
provide uh that can guarante exactly
when processing for the streams has very
tight integration with storage in xpace
so that uh you get you you you can sure
that your data is you know really
processed and precis like all the ACT uh
um standard like the database uh
durability atom atomicity those kind of
things is uh always
guaranteed uh and also has a UI
management and really easy uh
application development uh API and why I
mention this is is because all this
thing is run on Hado uh using Yan as a
resource management okay so what is yarn
then okay so before I go into yarn so
many people actually Wonder so now I
have a bunch of machines I have a big
had Custer that can run a lot of M rued
job which is batch jobs right but the
question becomes like okay I don't have
that many B jobs keep running all the
time okay I got some spare resources or
I want to run a different type of
programs or different types of uh um
things for example real time stream for
example MP you know there are lots of
stuff that I want to Leverage The Custer
to run how can I do it
right so for example uh MPI is a very
common uh programming parandam that you
can find on big data right basically you
iteratively keep processing other data
rather than like map reduce is basically
one pass right you map and reduce and
that's it right so MPS like keep doing
uh iterations and then uh all the noes
and programs they can pass message to
each other to control to change the
state of this of the system it's very
common in machine learning uh this kind
of
algorithms or a streaming apps as I
mentioned like storm or the back flow
right uh it's not a B drop basically the
input is keep coming right so for
example you want to write something that
process uh web lcks of your web service
right so the locks never stops right
because your website is always up and
you keep you know getting a lot of loss
you want to do some real time processing
on it so that for example you can base
on the clicks and what the user clicks
on and what the user sees to change to
compute recommendations for the users is
a very common use case um many company
actually use it like Yahoo Facebook they
all based on this kind of real time
stream event processing to give you the
news fit the recommendations kind of
stuff um so it's kind of stream event
processing but it does share the
properties that you require a cust of
machines to process that like like
tremendous amount of data in a very
resilient way right or you just want to
use it to do some distributor load test
right you want to test your backend
system uh most of the time you find it
like okay I use single client but it's
very difficult to to load the server
right so you want to have multiple
clients to load the server at the same
time uh you got a bunch of machines in
in a custom why not just use those in
very if it is really easy accessible and
easy to use
right and at the end uh what we what we
envision is that uh you have a customer
that's a like lots of machines inside uh
you can run different type of
application on top of it right so for
example in this picture you can see like
traditional map mods you can see
realtime streaming you can see uh low
testing maybe not in the prodution
system but in some backend system uh MP
you know all sorts of uh programming
prodct that you can Implement on top of
it
so that's what Yan come into play so Yan
uh I think the full name is yet other
resource negotiator thank you um so
basically it's the resource manager for
Hado 2.0 uh in had in had one uh I
believe most of you will be familiar
basically it have the job tracker uh
that do the job right so now they
basically separate that out into a
separate um thing uh it's called Yan and
u
what it does is uh for managing the
resources on the whole Hado Custer and
then you can write some applications to
ask for resources on the customer so
that it will give you some resources
callede containers uh on the customer
and then you can run your own
application in it so basically in Hado 2
uh the M reduce is being implemented as
one type of yan applications okay but
then you can use Yan to implement your
own type of application as well uh so
basically this is what uh Yan does it
has a lot of uh good feature and nice
feature for managing uh resources like
for example you can uh you can actually
run it with uh lxc or c groups to limit
the number of cores or memories for each
of the containers uh it has very nice
scheduler that support uh preemptions uh
and support like ratios of uh resources
across the whole Custer so that you can
submit your job to different killes uh
and then they give you certain type
certain kind of uh uh uh resource
guarantee when you run the job you know
things like that there are lots of fancy
things that bu around the yarn which is
very very good and important and useful
libraries um so I'm going to give a very
very quick introduction to Yan since
most of you only heard of it maybe some
of you already know but uh anyway uh so
basically uh in Yan uh so you see the
pink box those are the yarn uh
components in yarn components there is
something called resource manager which
is the central piece is like a master
for managing who knows about everything
of the customer everything about the
resources of the customer and then in
each node there's something called node
manager that uh runs locally which
responsible for launching and managing
the containers that run on that that
particular box uh and the resource
manager will know the existence of the
note manager and then uh will
communicate with it for acquiring or
releasing uh containers uh which call
resources sometimes called containers um
and then as an application programmer or
you want let's say you want to write a
application that runs on Y what you have
to do is you basically have to write two
things uh rather than one right normally
when you write write a uh want to
develop an application you write one
thing which is your application but in y
case you have to write two things the
first thing is called application master
um uh that yellow box the am is the
application Master which responsible for
for communicating with the resource
manager to ask for more resources on the
whole Custer to run your own to run your
actual applications so to pick to make a
very simple example let's say you want
to run a web server on the Yan Custer
what you have to do is is you first have
to write a application master and then
deploy that application uh through the
Yan client which you have to write some
code it's not a lot but you have to
write some code to deploy the young uh
uh to deploy your app apption master and
then inside application Master you have
to write the logic to ask the resource
manager for more containers to run your
actual web server and then you have to
monitor those and then you have to
reclaim like if you if you want to
increase number of instances or you want
to decrease the instances you know all
those interaction is done by the
application Master uh with the resource
manager so basically you have to write
uh actually quite a lot of code uh to
communicate with Yan just for that that
purpose uh it's not even talking about
your own application yet but of course
in your own application you still have
to interact with the container a little
bit um so that it can like uh play like
the whole application can work
nicely uh and also lot to mention the
things that are missing like the real
time loss collections or metrix
collections Discovery service so we find
that there are lots of things that
developer have to build to make it
useful easy enough to build applications
on top of young so that's why we think
that uh Yan is not simple and that's why
uh we come up with
we so there are certain pain points uh
that we discover when we try to use yarn
initial initially and this is actually
the major reason why we try to build
with to kind of not letting any everyone
to go through pain and suffering that we
go through and we try to abstract those
out as a library so there are a couple
things um so basically for anyone if you
try to use Yan uh everyone that that we
have been talked to is actually pretty
pretty difficult the the learning curve
is very very STI you you can easily take
like two weeks without write without be
able to write any single line in your
application um if you really like trial
you have trial right you
agree and um if you look at the sample
applications that are provided by Yan
80% or even 90% of the code AOL upate so
in Yan
I will show you later but in the in the
Yar distribution they come with a
examples called distributed shell as the
name suggests a distributor shell
basically allows you to run a shell
command across the whole customer okay
that's what it does and guess how many
lines of code it takes for
that any
guess 100 five yeah no so in the example
is in the first version that they come
up with actually takes 1,500 lines for
that okay and then in later version they
have improved the API a little bit but
it still takes around thousand lines for
just writing application that execute a
shell command on the whole Custer okay
so that's the amount of prod PL I'm
talking about right effectively it takes
maybe two lines or three lines of code
right including the Java produ place
maybe five lines of code right you can
execute a command but it takes 1,000
lines at least for just doing that you
know
yeah and the other thing is originally
Yan is not built uh for long running
application uh many of the focus is for
running map with this job which it runs
it may run for a long time but
eventually it will
terminat uh we want to we we want to use
it for running long running applications
like for example stream event processing
web service uh you know all sorts of
stuff that can be long running never
ends uh so the support on yarn on on
running this type of application is not
is not very very good and um uh actually
there's a panning ticket that uh Yahoo
opened on supporting the long run
application in Yan esec especially
around the security token things uh I
can go into details later but I'm not
going to details now but basically
they're not really built for long run
application so it Miss a lots of things
like law collections uh metrics and
realtime monitoring State transtion you
know those kind
stuffs and uh while as I mentioned
there's no ST support for application
life cycle so all you can do is
basically submit a job it runs it
terminates that's the things you support
right but how about you want to increase
the number of instances or reduce it or
like pause your applications do some
upgrades you know all those kind Stu are
all not supported you have to do it on
your own that's why you have to write so
many code in your application
Mon and um yeah so basically and also
it's very difficult to debug uh if if
you have tried to do it uh because
basically the the first pin point is
when you run when you submit your
application it runs you don't know
whether whether it's a it or not you you
don't well sometime it fails without any
reason okay uh and then you have to go
into every single machines to look at
the locks uh in order to figure that out
so it it's really really painful if you
have a customer of like 20 machines it's
not a big Custer right 20 machines but
still you have to go to like 20 holes
and you have to write scripts and SS
into those you know it's it's really
really painful to do that
and so what we think is we we we are not
trying to tackle like every single type
of application but most of the time for
typical Yan application or typical
distributor application what it needs is
relatively simple right so you have your
application you want you want to run
multiple instances on the Custer at the
same time and then you you want to have
way to scale it you want to have way to
collect the logs and metrics you want to
have a way to discover the existant of
them like which uh which machine which
Port they branding on right those kind
of stuff is pretty standard right so and
also we think that most Java developers
are familiar with threets right when
writing runnables or threats is very
very familiar to most of D developers so
what if we make running distributed
applications just like creating a new
fles and then you run it right that's
what we try to
do um so this typical list I've already
go through right so scale R uh long
range jobs collections sorts of things
so that's come with um so with uh the
name as name imply we try to make yarn
in order right so it's less messy it's
easy to use it might not fit every
single applications but at least so far
it fits all the applications that we try
to build and we like web server like
realtime streaming like uh low testing
like MP most of the applications that we
see actually can fit in this model uh um
and in fact we have like like plans or
projects that try to uh start or run HB
on Yan through weave as well um so it's
kind of an ongoing project but we are
looking at that level of application so
it's not like toy application it's real
applications that we can
run so and that's the motivation right
we try to make it simple easy as simple
as writing fast using a paradigms that
is most familiar to most of the uh Java
developers uh already uh existing Java
developers and we try to hide as many
lowlevel details of Yar so what we try
to do is when we build API we try to
make it simple and easy to start with
but also powerful and and like powerful
enough to like fit in most of the
situations so that's what we try to do
um so what we provide in in in wave is a
very simple set of API I'll show you
right after this two slide after this
and also simplify the way of managing
the the whole application life cycle
like scaling it uh terminating it stying
commands all sorts of things uh and also
we we provide generic application Master
which kind of good enough of fit for
most applications not every single
applications but like most
applications uh and also we Tred to
abstract out some of the ppint that uh
uh Yan have to do like for example
simplify the archive management uh I'll
go for a little bit more on this one uh
and also better control on on the
logging and the errors and and the
metric as well
and okay so I'm always emphasized on
Simplicity this is the level of
Simplicity I'm talking about so in on
the left is the distributional example
in here is set 500 lines because we kind
of trim out all the bo place that are
not really core to the application okay
so the whole application is like 1,000
lines if it trim out all those it still
takes 500 lines the the core part that
needed for running the distribut shell
if we write the same thing you using
weave the whole program end to end like
the whole main method like everything it
takes around 50 LS that's the level of
simplifications that we're talking about
for
we so how to do that um so we'll look at
the API right after this one but in
terms of architecture basically it use
uh it's very similar to what you have
seen before right for the Yan uh
architecture but what we provide is
something what we call a we Runner or we
Runner service that is the client which
uh you submit your uh your application
through and then what you have to
construct is basically something for
what we call we runnable uh the with
runnable is an interface that extend
from runnable and then you implement the
run method with some life cycle method
as well uh and then you can deploy your
runable and run it on a customer when
you Deploy on the customer uh we also
deploy together with the we application
master that manage applications and then
your runnable will be shipped to the
customer and run uh within the container
that we get from Yan uh based on the
specification you set let's say you want
to run 10 instances of 10 instances of
it then we'll get 10 containers and run
10 instances of uh of your runnable or
let's say you have multiple multiple
runnables that you want to run that
contribute to your applications will
like do whatever you said right based on
the specification that you provide and
then we use suuper uh as the
coordination uh coordination uh service
for the um life cycle and Estate
Management and also message passing
between the client the application
master and the application Master to the
actual run level as well so that you can
actually send uh command to your
applications so for example you want to
um send some command and change the some
uh behavior of the application you can
do that as well um or you can tell it to
stop this particular or suspend this
particular run and then do some changes
and then uh to database or whatever it
is and then you resume it you can do
that as
well okay so now let's see how the API
looks like so this is the kind of the
simplest form let's say you want to run
a very very simple thing okay uh in this
in this example it's just a a toy okay
it's the standard Echo server Network
Echo server right so what you have to do
is you just write your class right Echo
server just like you used to and then
you implements the we runable instead of
implements
runev uh and then you implement the run
method of course right and then in the
run me you just do the standard stuff
you start the server you you start
listening and then you bind to it
right and and that's it right that's no
different than a standard Java
applications that's how your application
look like the next part is the
deployment of the application right um
so we have something called we Runner uh
that you construct from the library uh
so basically you construct like wh
Runner new uh y with with Runner and
then you get the instance of the runner
and then you say prepare to run a new
Echo server okay so you prepare to run
this thing and then in the prepare
method you actually return like a
builder uh we call a prepara that you
can like alter the behavior a little bit
uh so there are a bunch of methods over
those uh but the simplest thing you
could do is let's say you want to attach
a lock Handler that simply just print
the locks to your uh system out okay um
so in this case is just printing but
then let's say you're running multiple
instances of the echos server across
your customer you see all the locks in
the client you don't have to go to S
every single machines to see the locks
right you you see the Lo all the locks
right away you you have the St tray will
point to like exactly where it it is
right where exactly where the locks get
uted and then after the the preparation
you say stop then your application will
stop it will run on the
custom um and after you start it returns
you a controller so a controller is the
interface for you to interact with your
applications so you can stop your
applications through the controller um
you can uh send command like this case
it send a command to tell the echo
server to change the port that it listen
to for examples um or you can suspend it
or you can like you know do different
things depending on what the controller
allows you to do um and that's it that's
the thing that's the way you build your
first distributed applications so
imagine that this is not Echo server
imagine that this is a a web server a
NTI a NTI service that you built right
you don't have to modify your your
original nety service all you need to do
is to wrap it a little bit with a with
runnable then it become a distributor
application
automatically that's the level of
Simplicity we talk
about okay so the the the next API I'm
going to show as uh a slightly more
advanced case is let's say you want to
your application actually consists of
multiple runnables
uh yes so this case consists of multiple
runnables how do you how do you uh um
construct it so we have something called
a uh with application which basically is
like a collection it's like a
specification that specify collections
of runnables that you want to run as a
single application okay so you basically
implement the with runnable and then uh
with application and then there's only
one method that you have to implement is
the configure method that return a
specification and then there's a builder
that that help you to build a
specification that basically say there's
a name of my that's the name of my
application and have I have some
runnables so with runnables and say so
the first runnable I have is a jetty web
server uh it's a web server that using
Ed J okay and then the Highlight part is
when I add this runable I can also add
with files that will get localized to
The Container okay so this is very
important in a way that because the the
for example the web server that you
write when it serve um the request it
serve from its local directory right
serve from its local file system xtml
file JS whatever file it is right Ser
from it local file system but when you
run your application on a Custer you
don't know which machine it is running
on you don't know like where it will run
that Mach it may run on one machine but
that one will fail it will switch over
to the other one right and so on and so
forth you might be able to like add a
new machine to the Y customer and then
you want to add more custo uh add more
instances of your applications to run on
the new machine as well so one way to do
it of course when you set up the machine
you always set up all the all the all
the files that will possibly be needed
by your applications on all the machines
right but normally no one would do that
right so uh what you what normally what
you do is to use a features called
localized file in Yan that basically um
it can localize any HFS files to your uh
to the local file system uh of the
machines that in the custom okay but in
order to do that if you do it through
the yarn API it's actually not very
respectful and easy it's like a lot of
BPL you can easily like just write 50
Lin of code for for transporting one
files for that um so the we API allows
you to do that by let's say you have the
files in a client right which is pretty
typical right you can package your file
together with your client and then you
say with local files uh you have a name
for the files and then you have the path
to file then boom everything under the
directory or CP or whatever it is it
will get shipped and become available at
the container local directory when the
runnable is started so that you don't
have to modify your your own application
you can still write your application as
reading from local files you can easily
test it without Yar without WID and then
once everything is set you can deploy it
and then we will make sure that the file
will be appear in the local D local file
directory and so you can add a lot of uh
local files and then you can say apply
and then you can add another varable so
lock collector for example is an another
runnable which is a different service
that you run on a custom but it belongs
to part of the the uh this web server
application as well uh what it does it
it really depends on what you do but for
this one it's like okay collecting logs
from Jett for example you can do
whatever you want you can have AR amount
of uh runnable as well as long as uh
your customer have enough capacity to
run all those that would be fine right
and then at the end I say any order
which means uh all these runnable will
kind of start simultaneously not really
simultaneously because it really depends
on uh the container that returned by Yan
uh because the mechanism of working with
Yan is like uh the application Master
ask for a
container uh but Yan won't give it to
you right away so it's also asynchronous
so you ask for it and then you keep
pulling and then sometime it might give
you one container it might give you two
containers let's say you ask for 10
containers this time might give you five
next time give it give you two and then
next C give you free okay so any other
basically means whenever the container
is available it will start it okay um so
we also support uh I'll show you in the
next slide but we also support like all
the starting for example you want to say
like start this one first and then start
the next one and start so we also
support that as
well and so now you build your
application you basically start your
application in the same way as as before
so you have the runner the the we Runner
and then you prepare your application uh
you can like still modify modify the
behavior a little bit through the pra
and then you say stock you get a
controller you can control your
application in the same
way this is another samples of showing
the applications like um the the
Highlight is like the the ordering so
you can say first start the reader and
then start the processor and then start
the writer so on so forth so we can
specify The Ordering of starting uh of
the runnable uh not just one instance of
the runnable but multiple instances of
the runable uh so uh it's not sh in this
uh examples but actually when you add a
run you can also say um I want to run 10
instances of this run level rather than
one by one right so you can just start
it and also uh the API Support called
Resource Management which exactly the
same thing that I just said uh you can
actually set the number of virtual
course uh uh that are needed or used by
your rable uh but this one is remember
it's actually virtual course uh which is
uh not NE necessarily tied to a real CPU
core it all depends on how Yar is being
configured it's like a ratio between
what you configured and what you say in
the here okay but anyway so you can
specify the number of CES and memory
size and number of instances uh uh and
uh in future potentially you can specify
like the network bandwidth for that as
well uh because like all those is as
long as those are supported by the Alexy
the the Linux uh control group um those
can be specified uh through API and Y as
long as Yan support it uh you be able to
use those as well uh and then so this is
the one example you specif resource and
then you start things and more or less
the same way okay and actually through
the through the controller uh you can
also cury the resource usage of your
applications because the thing is even
you ask for two calls uh or even you ask
for a certain amount of memory the J may
not give that to you right or it may
give more to you okay so you can curate
the the report for the actual amount of
resources they're being used uh as of
that particular moment so it's easy for
you to generate like resource report uh
pting graphs you know that kind of
things we actually using it to uh
generate what we call uh what we call
resource view uh for the whole
customer and also through the controller
you can uh dynamically change the number
of instances for individual runnable so
let's say you want to increase the
number of instances of web service you
can simply just send a uh change
instance command through the controller
boom and that's it it will be
done um okay so I'm almost ti so road
map um so right now the weave library is
open source we uh starting a aachi
incubator process uh we just started um
we hope to get it into aach incubator so
that we can get more and more
contributed for the whole uh thing and
build a community around it um so as of
the
current status um we have released that
work with Hado 2.0 uh and then Hado 2.1
they just released a a version of it
that is like two weeks ago we already
have a and then in haduk 2.1 actually
they change they have a major change in
the API of yan basically they change
everything um so we have a branch uh in
the with respository that can work in uh
had2 as well uh we we'll merge it uh
soon uh that and then then we'll have a
version that work with 2.0 and then have
another version that work 2.1 as
well uh Resource Management through
cgroups as I mentioned uh is in the
branch is working uh is planning to
merge into uh Dev Branch as
well um and then there then down below
there's all like uh future features that
we want to have
um and we uh defin definitely would love
to hear more from the community like
what kind of things that we expect from
these kind libraries as well um so we're
looking for like more flexible life
cycle management through the application
master so for example right now
application Master is pretty fixed it
fixed logic in it um but we looking for
like adding hookes for you to run some
custom logic in the application master
so that you can decide like for example
if a particular Runner are runable or
container start what you want to do do
you want to restart it or do you want to
just forget about it or do you want to
terminate the whole application
so it's slightly different across
different applications so we're looking
for like building hul so that you can
write custom code and of course we will
have like default uh configurable oh
okay so by default it it will be like
shutting down application or by default
it just restart or something like that
um and also we are looking for like
slightly more advanced ear handling like
rather than like always always weart or
always die um maybe it can keep track of
like the the percentage of failure and
then like make some decision based on
that as well
um and Expendable extendable application
Master as mentioned we want to be able
to allow someone to extend the uh
application master and run your own
extension rather than like always run
with a fix version as we provided um
support for long jbm language uh so you
can see the whole API is like Java
Centric so we also looking for like long
jvm well as of the current version
technically it can runs any jvm language
like Scara or like pooser or like
anything that can run in jvm you can
kind of run it you might have to write
more code for to adapt the class or
things like that but technically it can
be run but we're looking for like
running long JM language as
well um support for more standard
command dispatching because as right now
the command is pre- custom so you have
to send your own command and you handle
it in your own way maybe we can come up
with some standard command well actually
right now there's two standard command
one is stopping the application or
stopping a runable the other is the set
changing number of instances of a
particular runable
um and also we looking for like
contributions and and we kind of working
closely with the community uh running HP
using with is one of our goal uh if you
have know there's some there's a project
called Hoya uh hbas on Yan that um is
kind of similar to W but in the way that
they write for specific things for
running hbas on Yar but in fact with
weave you can construct HB on yar
quickly like you just run uh write two
runnables one for the master one one for
the xage master uh one for the region
server and then you just deploy through
with
API also like a web server you know all
sorts of stuff that we would like to
have like like to see contributions to
the we project as
well um we like to support Uh custom
level metric right now there's no
there's no support so which means you
cannot emit metric and then the and then
have to with uh framework to collect it
um better UI and um the last two is uh
the the bottom two is kind of like the
ability to De uh remote debug so this
one is kind of in Far Future it's not in
near future because we would like to see
like because right now the way to debug
is you deploy and then you observe the
logs or you insert logs and see how it
change but you cannot attach a debugger
because the program actually runs on
multiple machines remotely um so we
we're looking for way to like have a way
to centralize the uh debugging and
attach attaching debugger to the remote
applications and of course uh improving
API although we think that the current
API is good uh but believe when like the
community evolve like when we have more
and more use cases the API will have
need to to improve it as
well and
so if you are interest if you want to
start uh is uh open source is propit on
GitHub uh G up.com
continuity and then we have lots of docs
documentations with examples uh in
w.c.com
and lastly we are hiring um so anyone
who interest will think that the things
that we work on are cool and useful to
the community useful to to Big Data
development please feel free to contact
us uh contact me and uh for any channel
career careers con.com or go to website
or link maintain whatever it is okay we
hiring a lot of positions Engineers we
especially interest in Engineers Senor
Engineers uh B data Engineers platform
Engineers as
well um thank
you do I have time for questions
or sure any question I'll mic
along yeah sure
you mentioned about agation as far asame
how do you basically Agate based on the
time or you talk something about you
mean uh you talk about the LW
aggregations uh okay so the question is
how does the law aggregation works in
the wh so basically how it works is when
we start the application Master we start
a embeded CA server uh as you can see in
the slides let me show you the slides
back the way back
um right here oops right here so in the
application
Master right here so when it starts it
start with a CA server and then when we
start the Y container all of them um
will have a log appenders slf forj Los
loog appender implemented to publish all
the logs to the C server so the ordering
is basically based on the the time you
publish uh so it's not stly orders
across all the containers uh you can
easily Implement a lock handlers um so
as seen in
here so right this one is simply just
prined right but you can Implement your
own lock Handler to do some buffering
and sorting before you print it out or
before you process it because normally
when the containers are all up and
running the lack time between the the
proper should be relatively small So
within like couple seconds so can you
can easily write a lck Handler that
maybe perer second before you you frush
it out or something like that but
basically that's how it works okay you
see performance because that trying
toiz um so as of right now we don't
really see performance issue uh first is
kfka itself is really really scaleable
in terms of discount po subscription
second thing is uh normally you you
don't have a lots of losss to publish uh
unless you run in Trace mode right but
normally you don't run trace mode in
prodution right you only run trades in
maybe debugging or things like that in
which performance is not really that
important in that sense so if it's talk
about like normal logs like info logs or
War L those log is not really issue for
for the c um so in length actually I
used to work in L before so in length
they use CER to collect like all the uh
logs and metric and everything that's
seen in the LinkedIn website through c
as well of course they have a bigger C
customer uh but the thing is the C
itself is really really highly
scalable
yes you briefly talk about the advantage
of running H
in running okay uh you want me to talk
about how to run HP on
y oh okay so the advantages of running
hpas on Yar so the the reason for that
is so for example let's say you have a
customer of machines okay uh you want
you want to build a a a platform as a
service right so someone would need a
Hado someone does uh someone would need
the HR someone doesn't someone want to
have a small hbas Custer that comes and
go it doesn't have to run all the time
right so for example the hbas is only
needed for the lifetime of a particular
map with jobs or particular application
only so you can easily useing yarn or F
weave right to start a hbas a relatively
small HB Custer on Yan and just run it
and use it for that particular
application and then you still prist the
data because that's what HB does and
then you shut down HB server next time
application run it starts again it still
read all the old data but you have the
hbas to use I mean that's one type of
application the other one is like um
you're running a lot of different uh
hbas Custer across the whole Hado Custer
to do like HB
Custer
yes
because so the um okay the
question right so the question is we can
do this because HR doesn't really
require HFS uh well the thing is the one
of the prises as of right now yarn
require HFS so whatever you have yarn
you have HFS already and normally
normally I would say when you run hbas
in production you run with HFS right you
don't run well you can run with some
other file system but I will say
majority run with HFS and in fact Yan
does come with HFS um so when you start
hbas your side of yarn is already of HFS
you don't have to set another
HFS yes is there any notion of
priority which can be specified applic
these applications have higher prior and
also right so the question is is there a
way to specify priority for different
applications when you try to like
specify your applications right uh when
it runs on a y Custer uh So currently
the Yar allows you to configure uh
different schedule C uh but it's not
really priority uh because in a way that
the the schedule killes allows you to
specify a particular uh uh resource
guarantee and then but you might get
more you might get less uh but strictly
speaking it's not really like like
process priority as of right now uh but
the Yan Community is actually working
something on that uh
but
provides
right so um so as long as Yan would have
those we'll expose it through the API
but right now because there's no really
standard way or good way to do it yet so
that's why it's not Expos as of the API
right now but yeah it makes sense to
expose those as well like configuring
which kills to run on and and the
priority of the applications should I
get PM or not you know things like that
right now it's not supported for API yet
okay how does Yan compare to misil um I
may not be the perfect person to speak
for this uh I don't have deep experience
in misos uh all I know is misos compared
to Yan is relatively small in terms of
the coase and the
functionalities um so what MOS does I
don't know the latest of the resource
though so what I knowe about resource is
uh it do Resource Management it does it
through C uh c groups um and more or
less that's that's it right and then you
have to build a lots of custom things on
top while Yann is a a much bigger
framework it tightly integrated with
Fass so that it support like local files
as I mentioned um uh and then it defines
like application Master the failure mode
you know things like that and also
scheduling not scheding but the resource
skills and and pre
you know it has like more things on top
of it um so it's really difficult to
compare one comparison I would look at
is Hadoop itself or the Hadoop ecosystem
is a very big ecosystem it's have a very
big commodity around it um so Yan is
definitely going to survive it's not
going to go away uh because the whole
Hado is running on it the next
generation of whole Hado thing is
running on it misos I don't know there's
some company that's starting to use me
and Building Things around it uh but I
don't know how big the the community is
like how well it will get developed in
long term but how do like I don't have
to mention like how big it is right how
well it get like funded by different
companies and like big companies
actually like Yahoo Microsoft fabook
Facebook they put a lots of resources
just to contributing like using it and
contributing it back to the
community any more questions maybe the
last one if this any any more
questions great okay okay thank
you